this episode is brought to you by
expressvpn
what is vpn virtual private network it's
an app that you run on your computer or
your mobile device it secures your
internet connection
hides your public ip address and lets
you bypass regional restrictions on
content and i actually asked my
followers on twitter 1.5 or 1.6 million
of you
for vpn recommendations your favorites
many wrote back
that expressvpn was their favorite
including a number of people who've been
on this podcast
so i gave it a shot and it is
ridiculously
fast to the extent that i thought i
didn't have it on
to give you an idea expressvpn is
consistently rated the fastest vpn
service on the market
it's incredibly easy to use and it's one
two three just download the app
tap one button and you're connected to a
secure vpn server
so expressvpn what are we talking about
here expressvpn is great for when you
need to get work done while you're on
some sketchy wi-fi network for instance
and i've had
a number of hacker friends of mine show
me how easy it is to snoop on public
wi-fi
just by downloading simple apps you do
not need a computer science background
to do that which scares the hell out of
me
so if you don't want to be a victim of
that you can use
expressvpn expressvpn is useful not only
for entrepreneurs
and remote workers and travelers like
yours truly
but really for anyone who wants
protection from being snooped on or
having their personal data
stolen so i use it constantly when i'm
in airports coffee shops and so on
any public wi-fi really you just use the
internet like you normally would
but with expressvpn encrypting all of
your network traffic to safeguard your
data
so check it out visit my special link at
expressvpn.com10
and you'll get an extra three months of
expressvpn protection for free
that's expressvpn.com tim to claim your
special deal
visit expressvpn.com
this episode is brought to you by all
form if you've been listening to this
podcast for a while you've probably
heard me talk about helix
sleep and their mattresses which i've
been using since 2017. i have two of
them
upstairs from where i'm sitting at this
moment and now helix has gone beyond the
bedroom and started making
sofas they just launched a new company
called all form
a-l-l-f-o-r-m and they're making premium
customizable sofas and chairs shipped
right to your door
at a fraction of the cost of traditional
stores so i'm sitting in my living room
right now
and it's entirely all form furniture
i've got
two chairs i've got an ottoman and i
have an l sectional
couch and i'll come back to that you can
pick your fabric
they're all spill stain and scratch
resistant the sofa color
the color of the legs the sofa size the
shape to make sure it's perfect for you
and your home
also all form arrives in just three to
seven days and you can assemble it all
yourself in a few minutes no tools
needed i was quite astonished by how
modular
and easy these things fit together kind
of like lego pieces they've got arm
chairs love seats all the way up to an
eight seat
sectional so there's something for
everyone you can also start small and
kind of build on top of it if you want
to get a smaller couch and then build
out on it which is actually in a way
what i did because i can turn
my l sectional couch into a normal
straight couch and then with a separate
ottoman
in a matter of about 60 seconds it's
pretty rad so
i mentioned i have all these different
things in this room i use the natural
leg finish which is their lightest color
and i dig it i mean i've been
using these things hours and hours and
hours every single
day so i am using what i
am sharing with you guys and if getting
a sofa without trying it in store sounds
risky you don't need to worry all form
sofas are delivered directly to your
home with fast free shipping
and you get 100 days to decide if you
want to keep it that's more than three
months and if you don't love it they'll
pick it up for free and give you a full
refund
your sofa frame also has a forever
warranty that's literally
forever so check it out take a look
they've got all sorts of cool stuff
to choose from i was skeptical and it
actually worked it worked
much better than i could have imagined
and i'm very very happy so
to find your perfect sofa check out
allform.com
tim that's a-l-l-f-o-r-m dot com slash
tim all form is offering 20
off all orders to you my dear listeners
at allform.com
tim make sure to use the code tim at
checkout
that's allforum.com tim and use code tim
at checkout at this altitude i can run
flat out for a half mile before my hands
start to shake
can i answer your personal questions
[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the tim ferriss show
where it is my job to interview
world-class
performers from all different
disciplines all different areas to tease
out
habits frameworks lessons learned tools
that you can use
insights that you might apply to your
own life questions
that might enable you in some fashion
my guest today is close friend
adam gazzali mdphd you can find them on
twitter at adamgaz gaz
adam is the david dolby distinguished
professor of neurology
physiology and psychiatry at the
university of california san francisco
and the founder and executive director
of neuroscape a translational
neuroscience
center engaged in technology development
and scientific research
of novel brain assessments and
optimization tools dr ghazali is
co-founder and chief
science advisor of achilles interactive
sensing and jazz
venture partners he has been a
scientific advisor for more than a dozen
technology companies including apple
ge nielsen and deloitte cazalli has
filed multiple pallets
try that again let's try that might keep
that one in
because ali also does never refer to as
gazali anyway gazali i like it though
gazzali has filed multiple patents
notably his invention of the first video
game cleared by the fda authored more
than 150 scientific articles and
delivered over
675 invited presentations around the
world god that makes me exhausted just
reading it he wrote and hosted the
nationally televised pbs special the
distracted mind with dr adam gazzali
and co-authored the distracted mind
subtitle ancient brains in a high-tech
world winner of the 2017 pro's award dr
gazzali has received many awards and
honors
including the 2015 science educator
award and the 2020
global gaming citizen honor you can find
him
online in several places gazali.com as
well as
neuroescape.ucsf.edu
and on social on facebook instagram
twitter
adamgas and you can also find him on
linkedin he is easy to find there aren't
many adam gizalli's running around
adam welcome back to the show thanks so
much tim excited to be here with you
i am excited also because you have what
appears to be a professional
sports center broadcasting headset
those who are not watching video can't
see it but
i am very reassured that if this
neuroscience thing doesn't work out for
you you have
a compelling plan b it was you know
quite a way to overdo
the zoom world that we live in now with
this headset but at least for this
podcast i will be well heard so thank
you
and thanks to matt moldwig also for his
his tech neighborhood
so for people who did not join us
in the first conversation we had on the
podcast i wanted to
mention a few highlights
or just a few topics that we brought up
so the
first conversation we had i didn't
realize until doing prep for this
conversation
because there was a summary of our
previous conversation which said
kevin and daria rose are moving to new
york and i thought to myself
good god how long ago was that it was
2015. so in 2015
it's been a long time and your bio has
developed quite a bit since
and the title of that was the maverick
of brain optimization
and i'll mention a few reasons for
choosing
that title and that was my choice i
don't think you would choose that for
yourself
we discussed many things and i want to
paint
a picture of some of the
tools and types of development that you
have
explored in your time as as a scientist
and
one of those is neuroracer which is a
piece of software that was featured on
the cover of
nature the title as i remember it was
game changer
and when you correct me if i'm wrong
i'll just try to summarize this really
quickly but
the paper was able to show that a team
of scientists could work with video game
professionals to build something
customized that targets process in the
brain that's deficient in a certain
population
i'm going to ask you to just give some
numbers in a minute but in this
particular case it was older adults and
their cognitive control abilities
so some might say age-related cognitive
decline
and then you once you've built the
software
you can construct a carefully controlled
study placebo-controlled and neural
measurements to document the mechanisms
of effect and show that you can create
sustainable and meaningful changes in
the brain
using a video game and just as a
footnote
that cognitive abilities begin to
decline around
or certain cognitive abilities around
what early to mid 20s
that's accurate so what were some of the
outcomes of the study or the paper that
was
that was featured on the cover of nature
yeah that was uh really
quite a game changer for for me as well
only time has told
how far that technology and that
research has gone and we could dive into
what it's become
now it's fun to think back you know that
paper was published in 2013
and it took five years of both tech
development to build that video game
with
friends at lucas arts as well as to do
the multiple research studies that went
into that paper in nature
and why it was so exciting was that what
we were able to show was that
we could improve the ability of these
healthy 60 plus
year olds not just to play the game but
their ability to sustain their attention
in a very boring context as well as
their working memory
holding information in mind for short
periods of time and what we were showing
is that we were really improving
and their ability to multitask on the
game two levels of
20 year olds so it's really reversing a
lot of the changes that occur with
healthy aging
and we could see those changes occurring
not just in terms of their performance
but neurally because we recorded with
high density eeg
how they responded to these challenges
before
and after a month of gameplay we could
then look
over time six months later and actually
we have a paper
that is just being accepted for
publication now showing
six years later that in these older
adults we see some benefits not all the
benefits retain over that period of time
which is really quite exciting it opens
up the possibility to really
push what we can do to lead to these
sustainable
benefits what was the age range of
subjects roughly or the
average they were 60 and over
i think we had one that was a 90 year
old but mostly 60 and 70 year olds
and the game the software was
as an intervention was able to restore
or revert some of their cognitive
function to the level of
20 somethings correct accurate yep that
that's accurate
and just to restate what you said for
people who might have
missed it the and please again correct
me if i'm wrong but there
the durability of the of effect in other
words seeing
the retention of a lot of these
improvements six months later
was not because they continued to play
this game on a regular basis
going forward correct they did not play
it at all
even though many of them wanted to after
the one
month of training and so that's why when
we
brought them back just recently this is
not published it'll be out soon six
years later
their ability to play that game at a
much higher level than they did before
was retained without any boosters and
this is not a real world
design because as this becomes a true
treatment intervention that we want in
the real world and we could talk about
where it's gone
we would not think about that type of
durability
as as the goal it would be more
reasonable
to boost those effects over time with
doses along the way
just like if you were going to enhance
your physical performance your
strength your aerobic ability you
wouldn't think oh a month in the gym and
then i'm good till six years later so
the fact that anything lasted is is sort
of mind-boggling to me as
a neuroscientist but um it's more of
a proof of concept that you know these
circuits and these abilities when they
change can be enduring
but in the real world implementation it
would make much more sense
to in a personalized way boost these
effects
along the passage of time for those not
involved in scientific research what
would you compare
being the cover of nature to i mean is
it comparable
to winning a an oscar for best director
or best picture i mean that's that's how
i've in some ways thought of it because
i don't have
perhaps other comparables but i know
you're very
self-effacing and humble when we talk
and also just in general but
it's a big deal it is not a small
accomplishment i'm just wondering how
you would
describe that or compare that to give
people an appreciation for what that
represents
yeah it's it's sort of around as big a
thing can happen
as a scientist and probably if it
happens it all will happen once in a
lifetime
you know having a paper in in nature
science those are like the pinnacle
journals in the world those two the the
twin towers
and having a paper in them is incredibly
rare and exceptional and then having a
cover story
is just a once in a lifetime and you
know my friend
mickey hart who's a musician he's the
drummer from the grateful dead he
he always jokes that oh that's that's a
cover of rolling stone that you know
so everyone sees it through their own
eyes but yeah to me i think it's like
it's like a grammy
and it's like a mixed feeling about it
because you get it and it changes your
life and it did you're like oh that
means that that was the pinnacle of my
life and everything after that is like
just not as good like it's not gonna
happen again and i have tried again
and we've had some really great papers
over the years but in all likelihood
that's the only time that's going to
happen in my life
well never say never never said that's
true i'm going to try i'll keep trying
now
so a few other things i'd love to note
the next is that
you i think
are very ambitious and
calculated at the same time so on one
hand
you might say that you
not just enjoy but look for risks that
you can take
say related to the video game connection
because you don't want to be
you personally and then i think maybe by
extension to your lab
this would also apply but you don't want
to be the scientist who is simply
building on whatever came before
in an iterative incremental approach
like is it fair to say that you are
looking for
groundbreaking discoveries or
groundbreaking development of tools is
that a fair statement
i've always been motivated i mean since
i was a little kid and
when i thought about science and you
know thinking about the giants and
history whose names you know you still
remember you know millennial later
those were my heroes not the baseball
players or
musicians it was always those scientists
and
looking at their accomplishments what
got me so excited about
going into science in the first place
and when you approach
science in that way you realize that
wanting to do it is only a piece
of the puzzle of getting there and even
having the ability and skills to do it
is still only a piece it's a convergence
of those things
and time frequently other events that
are outside of your control that all
lead to like a moment where you get to
make a contribution
at that level and that was always my
dream but it doesn't mean
it's going to happen to sort of answer
your question directly
in order to get there i tended to
think about the research that i wanted
to do from that perspective
and not just because i wanted a big
claim to fame because
not that that's not not a great goal but
my real goal is to make make a
meaningful
difference in humanity in in the world
and and help people
and i felt that in order to do that you
really have to
sort of step out of the box so to speak
and not be iterative and do
the thing that takes a little bit more
fearlessness and a little higher risk
and it's okay to fail but if you don't
try
then you know there is no chance that
you're going to make a difference at
that level
and so that's how i've always approached
it
along my career and i now that i've had
some successes in it you get even braver
i would say
and i want to give a few more examples
of
the types of tools and work that
you do within your lab i'll
first just read a quote from our first
conversation
asking and it was in response to me
asking what makes
your lab unique and please feel free to
fact check this but i believe it's
accurate
the question you ask yourself is how can
we use our expertise or methodology our
perspectives to not just
understand the brain but to try to
develop novel approaches to enhancing it
and then validating that our approaches
are actually effective
question mark that i believe was in the
first episode and
in the process of of following that
question
you've for instance studied how
electrical currents
can enhance brain function in
non-invasive approaches
with things like tdcs and this is i
suppose is as good a place as any to
segue
to a a new addition to your bio which
refers to this fda
clearance of a video game what does that
refer to my goals have always been to
not just have
a super long cv with lots of
recognitions and awards and
which is often what scientists even my
my great friends who i respect dearly
are building i i wanted to
do research that then leapt off the page
and became tools that would enter
people's lives and make it
make a meaningful difference to them and
i quickly realized that
i could not do that within the the
chambers of academia alone i had to
leave and not necessarily leave but i
had to cross over i had to find a way
to move technologies and invention and
discovery
from the lab into the real world in
order to do that
it involved working with industry in
some way
you don't really produce scalable
products in labs and academic labs it's
just not structured for that
and so the neural racer technology the
video game and
and really the methodology behind it
which was a patent that i filed at ucsf
that is now issued it took six years to
issue that
with that technology i co-founded a
company called achille interactive
with friends from the video game world
matt omarnick as well as
eddie martucci who was working with a
group pure tech ventures in boston
and we started this company achille
interactive to
move that technology and the nature
paper wasn't even out at the time that
we formed the company
beyond a prototype and an academic
exercise that leads to a paper even a
paper as good as a nature paper that
that wasn't the goal the goal was to
turn it
into a product that would be a medical
device that can
actually serve as a new form of medicine
beyond the molecular medicine is what i
now think of as an experiential medicine
or digital medicine
that could lead to improvements in
attention
in different clinical populations and so
over the last
seven years plus we we've now
at achille we've built a better version
of neuroracer
better meaning that it has higher levels
of art
and music and story and interactivity
and feedback loops
and usability but preserves the same
underlying architecture the same
mechanism that is defined
in the patent that was in neuraracer is
in this game called endeavor rx
and over these many years achille has
sponsored research at academic
universities
to validate this video game this
child of neuroracer as a clinical tool
as a treatment
in numerous populations so studies in
autism
and depression adhd multiple sclerosis
have been published now all converging
on the same conclusion that this game
can improve attention abilities in
these different populations so even if
there's a different
reason why an individual has an
attention deficit because they have
you know a sensory processing disorder
as a subset of autism
or they have depression we see the same
benefits which is really exciting
because you get that really broad effect
and so to go back to where you
introduced this
a study was done at a duke i was not
even an investigator
on that study which is that's the dream
right that you create the technology and
then
other colleagues and other independent
investigators
validate it so this was a study at a
dupe by a really great clinician
scientist scott collins
and it was a really unique study
methodologically because
it was a multi-site
double-blind placebo-controlled trial
with a video game
in children with adhd so 350 kids
years millions of dollars a big actually
not the type of studies i like to do at
all
but a big important study it's called
the phase three trial so it's a pivotal
trial it's the
it's the type of study you do that you
pre-submit to the fda
all your design elements your outcome
measures
it's like a baseball player you know
sort of pointing into the distance
saying
this next shot is going to be this home
run and how that's so much more
meaningful because you call it
in advance that's what you do in these
studies you have to like
pick your outcome measure and what you
expect to see before you even do this
study because that's the
most statistically rigorous way to show
that this is
a true effect and that's what was done
in this study that we
the hypothesis was that the sustained
attention of these children
which is very impaired beforehand they
have adhd
so sustained attention is vigilance in a
really boring environment it's designed
to be boring this test
that that would improve in response to
this video game compared to another
group of children with adhd that's
playing a different video game
and so that study took years and that
hypothesis
was confirmed that those children did
improve the other
group the other game didn't change at
all and so it was specific to this game
endeavor rx
and with that finding we
as achille presented to the fda the
results
requesting approval for clearance of a
medical device it's actually a class two
medical device to treat
inattention in children with adhd and
that took
many years just a point of detail if
folks are interested in this
that's known as a de novo pathway
there's two pathways through
the fda for either a drug or device one
is de novo meaning it's completely new
there's no predicate it's
essentially establishing a new category
of treatment and the other is the
predicate the 510k
pathway where it rests on a previous
history
and so it's much faster to get approved
through that pathway than the de novo
the new pathway
and so because there had been no video
game and no treatment of this type
ever cleared by the fda it was a de novo
pathway
which made it a lot longer and more
rigorous of a review process
but we found out during covet just in
the summer of 2020
that the game was cleared uh so this was
one of those small
blessings as my friend michael pollan
said a silver lining in the pandemic
blanket
and so what we found was
as we went through this process the fda
was willing to clear this
as a treatment for inattention in eight
to twelve year olds that's what the
study was
done on with adhd which was
just an amazing result after a decade of
journey from
new eraser to this because now what we
wound up with was the first
ever fda cleared digital treatment for
children and the first digital treatment
for adhd
and the first video game for any
clinical condition so
it was a long journey and i want to give
all the hundreds of people
at achille and neuroscape credit as well
as the independent investigators like
scott collins for
all the work and pushing it through but
now we have an entirely
de novo treatment of this type out there
for kids
this is exciting to me on multiple
levels one is
that as you mentioned it's de novo right
this is a
in a sense in several senses sort of
establishing
and validating a new category right
i mean that's a new category of of
treatment or intervention one question
that pops to mind
is what the underlying mechanism is or
if you can explain
why the game
endeavor rx seems to be effective
in multiple populations you named a few
depression
adhd autism or certain types of autism
multiple sclerosis we've now multiple
sclerosis
what is the even though these conditions
manifest and present
in very different ways in a bunch of
respects
what is the commonality or why is it
effective why is the intervention
effective across these different
conditions
yeah it's a great question and a
complicated
longer answer it would probably be
required to really
break it down but to just give you know
at least
a basic understanding of how that's
possible it really
is through the window of cognitive
neuroscience that that makes sense if
you look at the pathology of those
conditions it's
it's more confusing and elusive of why
they would be connected to have a common
treatment lead to benefits across them
but
from a cognitive neuroscience
perspective which is my background
over the last couple of decades is that
there are
common underlying networks neural
networks in the brain
that subserve different abilities like
attention memory decision making
emotional regulation on and on and
these networks could be damaged
influenced in all sorts of ways
by many conditions due to different
reasons when it comes to our attention
systems
the networks are so distributed that
any insult to the brain i would say i'd
be
bold to say that any real insult to the
brain that leads to any cognitive
deficit is going to have a component
of attention deficit associated with it
so if you look across all the
neurological and psychiatric conditions
that you can think of
and put it into pubmed or google scholar
with the word
attention or distraction you will find
research showing that they have
impairments in that and that's just
because
the act of focusing our limited mental
resources on something that
is a goal of ours which is you know the
core of the type of attention we're
talking about
sustaining selective focus on something
that you
choose to top-down attention that that
process involves so many distributed
brain areas that
all these different sources of pathology
lead to decrements in that ability and
so if you have an intervention
like neurorace or an endeavor rx which
challenges
cognitive control at a very high level
due to closed-loop systems in a
personalized way
like the ultimate trainer constantly
pushing
and optimizing those abilities over
weeks and even months sometimes
then what you wind up with is a transfer
of benefits to cognitive control
challenges outside of the game
that's independent of what the cause of
those deficits were
i think that's uh gives you a bit of a
of an idea of how you can have
a outcome that
sort of crosses all these boundaries
because the same
networks are vulnerable in all these
populations so anything that can
optimize them could lead to a benefit
across them
could you for people who don't have any
real perspective or context on ucsf
just describe ucsf like what is
ucsf from the perspective of
research or looking at it as an
institution of science
what is the best way for people to think
about ucsf in the kind of ecosystem
of research within the united states
it is a massive and humbling honor for
me to be at ucsf myself
it was always a dream to come out here
to california and work at this
institution
a lot of people don't know ucsf
university california san francisco like
they might familiar names like
stanford harvard mit largely because
a ucsf is only a medical and health
center we do not have an undergraduate
campus
there's no just engineering department
everything's bio bioengineering
biochemistry
but it is one of the world's premier
medical centers
pretty much across every domain
especially
in neuroscience neurology neurosurgery
psychiatry in those areas
in the brain areas is ucsf forte and
from many perspectives
and so it's always ranked as one of the
top in the country and even
at world measures when it's put to the
test or different evaluations and
from my perspective of being a faculty
member here for now 15 years
it's amazing i mean every f every other
faculty member i would meet
without knowing anything about them i'm
excited because there's something about
them
why they're here at ucsf that i just
want to find out um and then of course
from
from just a clinical perspective like i
would send anyone in my family or
without hesitation
and yeah it's just a wonderful wonderful
place to be a scientist
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show
this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront did you know
if you missed 10 of the best performing
days after the 2008 crisis you would
have missed out on fifty percent
five zero percent of your returns don't
miss out on the best days in the market
stay invested in a long-term automated
investment portfolio wealthfront
pioneered the automated investing
movement sometimes referred to as robo
advising
and they currently oversee 20 billion
dollars of assets for their clients
wealthfront can help you diversify your
portfolio minimize fees and lower your
taxes
takes about three minutes to sign up and
then wealthfront will build you a
globally diversified portfolio of etfs
based on your risk appetite and manage
it for you at an incredibly low cost
wealthfront software constantly monitors
your portfolio day in and day out so you
don't have to
they look for opportunities to rebalance
and tax loss harvest to lower the amount
of taxes you pay on your investment
gains
their newest service is called autopilot
and it can monitor any checking account
for excess cash to move into savings or
an investment account
they've really thought of a ton they've
checked a lot of boxes
smart investing should not feel like a
roller coaster ride let the
professionals do the work for you
go to wealthfront.com tim and open a
wealthfront investment account today
and you'll get your first five thousand
dollars managed for free for life that's
wealthfront.comtim
wealthfront will automate your
investments for the long term and you
can get started today at wealthfront.com
time
want to come back to the risk-taking the
concept of risk-taking for a second and
then we're going to talk about
new chapters we're going to talk about
new new areas when i hear you
talk about risk taking and
translating science into the world for
impact it strikes me that on
on one level you could look at some of
the projects and things that you've done
as risky in the sense there's a
possibility that they do not work and
they're
in many senses not incremental you're
not just adding an extra
five percent on top of something that's
already been demonstrated
at the same time when i look at how well
you've been able to recruit
and how well you've been able to retain
and how effectively you've been able to
build and grow this is a leading
question obviously but
would you agree that that ambition
and the willingness to take things that
one might consider
risky on as projects is a critical
ingredient in all of those things i just
i feel like to to foster an environment
where you can do all of those things
where people will put in lots of hours
and effort
over a long sustained period of time
like you mentioned
the years required for some of these
breakthroughs that that risk-taking is
seems to be a critical ingredient almost
a prerequisite for that
type of enthusiasm that's at least my
perception but
what are your thoughts i agree with you
i think that is
that's part of it and when you create an
entity i think
you know at the time that we last talked
it was my lab it was gazali lab that's
like a pretty classic way of how
labs are named after the pi and since
then my lab has just
exploded and now it's not a lab anymore
it's a center
where there are multiple faculty we have
now seven faculty members and
i think the reason that that has
happened is because of the type of
risk taking that i am willing to do
but also how we build we my whole team
builds a system of security
in that risk taking because it is a long
time to go without a publication when
you start one of these type of studies i
mean it could be five years before
you're
even writing up a paper and therefore in
order to
jump off of that you know that bridge
with your bungee on
you have to have security in the bridge
and in the bungee and in the and then
the instructors and the person that ties
it
on and so it's a whole community effort
to create the platform that allows risk
to be taken
in an appropriate way right because if
we were just
reckless who would join that and where
would be the means
to assemble an all-star team of
staff and post-docs and students and
faculty they just
they wouldn't gather so i agree with you
i think that
that's all tied together of what it
means to take a risk
to do something bold but to do it in a
way that's thoughtful
and not reckless and you used a term
just for people who may not recognize it
you said pi that is not magnum pi
private
investigates pr principle investigator
if i'm getting it right
correct yeah which refers to the the the
lead researcher for a grant project
how many folks do you have within the
neuroescape endeavor on that team
airscape's a center um
we just call it neuroescape and we have
over 40
people on payroll now and we also work
with a lot of contractors and volunteers
and that number's
well over 60. so it's a big group
and it's been a quite a change for me as
a pi
as a principal investigator to become a
director and to really
help other scientists upcoming in their
careers to
spread their wings and to really take
those calculated risks
as well under this you know community of
neuroscape that we created
you know it's so wild adam i just have
to say to think
back to when
we first started spending time together
looking at the evolution of the bio
reading it for the podcast just the
change
since 2015 and
seeing how much you have done since i
took also my first
my first step into the world of
scientific research from the standpoint
of funding with that very first
yeah that very first check yeah whenever
i think it was like 2012.
yeah 2012 something along those lines
for gazali lab
and uh it just makes me so happy to see
how incredibly well you've been able to
execute
and not just execute as an independent
soul scientist but also assemble
and retain top talent
it's very impressive to me i just wanted
to say that oh thanks it's also fun
so it's a real pleasure to talk with you
tim because we have
we have so much history going back over
a decade when we met
and i can't help but like you're doing
is thinking back in those early days
when
you even joined us for a bit on some
brain stimulation work to help us out
in the lab and just how much has changed
since then
it's fun to think back not just what the
list of papers are
but the the actual journey and and what
was involved in
in assembling the people and the
uncertainty even when we were talking
over the years
where the it was not fda cleared and it
was uncertain if it would be
because of all the challenges of get of
going through a de novo pathway so
it is really gratifying to talk to you
now after all these years
and see where we've come yeah i remember
trialing
very very early versions of neura eraser
with the
with the cap on
having exactly the eeg cap on and also
having
uh having you help i think it was my
middle finger to jump
kind of dance around with the tms
that applies to was it m3
yeah yeah yeah motor car tech sam
exactly so it's been
it's been a hell of a journey man and uh
and it's not over
so you not at all you are
i think it's fair to say you're in a
position
where you get to pick your targets i
mean you you have done
exceptionally well you've established
incredible defensible credibility
you've had game changer
neuroracer on the cover of nature you
have this
well-developed center right you have
neuroscale which is
is not just up and running but really
humming
right i mean it's it is a formidable
organization you can really choose what
you want to do and what you want to
focus on
so i suppose this is as good a place as
any could you please tell us
about what the new undertakings
are and i suppose the announcement and
we could start with the announcement and
then go into backstory just to hear how
you
got to this point or we could start with
the back story and then get to the
announcement
i agree let's not bury the lead we'll
we'll tell
but we'll tell what's going on and then
we'll
we'll break it down so that everyone
could enter this conversation
with that full knowledge so over the
next
couple weeks we're in the process of you
know announcing we're going through this
right now announcing
a new division within neuroscape that
will focus on
psychedelic research so neuroscape
psychedelic research division
is being launched and we're very very
excited about it we're also
really excited that this division will
have at its helm
robin carte harris who will be joining
us as faculty
at neuroscape and will be the director
of the center
and that's incredibly exciting for me
robin is
a leader in the field of psychedelics
has become a very
good and trusted friend and i'm honored
and and humbled in many ways that he is
he's willing to travel
across the world over from the uk to
join us to be the founding director of
this division
within neuroscape he'll also be coming
with an incredible
position the ralph metzner distinguished
professor of neurology and psychiatry
incredibly excited for him to start his
new journey within
ucsf and within neuroscape and to
advance psychedelic research
to the next level so that's the lead we
can talk about how all that happened
yeah let's let's talk about i also want
to just
note because i find it so incredibly
inspiring that things happened
very quickly and not just quickly
for within the scientific sphere but
quickly period
if i remember you know you look back at
email threads and just looking at
the sort of time period that transpired
after you first
connected with robin and as everything
unfolded it was very
fast and i think that's extremely
inspiring and
demonstrates what's possible within
universities that are and teams that are
able to
embrace this as a as a direction right
i just think it's incredibly impressive
yeah i'm really really pleased with how
rapidly
we've been able to do this especially
during covet you know nothing really
seems to happen fast during
these days and it just you know it's a
reflection of of the people involved the
university
and the fit of all those things together
the people the university and the
the research mission which is what i'd
love to spend time talking about that
those things allowed it to move so
rapidly and that it just
felt right and made sense from pretty
much every perspective
not that there wasn't a lot of logistics
and politics and
and negotiations but
the core of why this
was the right thing to launch this
division within neuroscape
to have robin lead it it just makes
sense
and so that with that force
all the other pieces are able to fall
into place
yeah well like with a big enough why
right a lot of the other things fall in
line
how did this come to be please share
whatever
you think might be helpful to paint a
picture of how and why this came
together
yeah it's great you know i've never
really told this story yet
and um i was sort of saving it to tell
with you
because you were one of the inspirations
in it not just a friend of mine but
you know if i go back to 2019
which is you know not all that long ago
even into
the sort of mid and late 2018
conversations that i had with friends
including you
about psychedelics as a medical tool
really ignited my imagination this was
sort of converging
with my own goals of thinking about what
i was going to do next as
as a scientist as an innovator to to not
be iterative i've had the success with
video games as as a therapeutic tool and
this was before the fda clearance and
there's so much more work to do in that
domain and we will do it and it is
it's a lifetime of effort to continue to
advance that but i was thinking about
the next decade
moving from 2019 into into 2020 and
beyond
and i was looking for something that was
not
brand new i don't want to plant a new
tree like i'll have more branches
and but i'm not going to start over from
the beginning it had to be within the
scope
of where i felt my expertise lied what i
what i enjoyed doing
the methodology and the skills of my
team at neuroscape
so it had a fit in that picture and i
started exploring what that would be and
when i heard my friends talking
about psychedelics you know i lived in
san francisco and
uh you know certainly a lot of people
here have you know
easy to find a conversation easy to find
a conversation
exactly and i i never really thought
about it from a scientific perspective
as a neuroscientist in that way which is
sort of says something you know i did an
md and a phd
i did a full neurology residency of it
ucsf
how come never during all of that
training
was psychedelics ever presented in a
academic manner as being a potential
tool
not once never which is fascinating and
we know a lot of
the political and social reasons why
that's true but it's still mind-blowing
when you think about that
given all of the neuro education that
i've had over the last
30 years but once i i started thinking
about it i
decided to dive in a little deeper and
the first thing was reading michael
pollan's book uh how to change your mind
i know you're also friends with michael
and i did not know him at the time we're
close by geographically he's at uc
berkeley and a professor there i'm at
ucsf like right across the bay half an
hour away
but we never met each other and i read
that book and
something did change in my mind and it's
really clear what it was
it wasn't just that i saw the clinical
potential of these compounds
that was obvious and i knew that already
it was that
what happened when i read that book was
that i realized
that these are not really molecular
treatments
they're not drugs in that classic sense
of
introduce a molecule lead to an effect
right just pop this in your mouth
and your cold is gone sort of like how
in the infectious disease world how we
think about drugs
i realized that these were experiential
treatments
and experiential medicines in much a
similar way to what i was doing with
video games
that it is the molecule that initiates
a series of events in your brain that
leads to an experience and that
experience leads to an outcome
and that outcome could be good or it
could be bad but it doesn't just depend
on the drug it depends on the
intersection of that
and you and the context around you and
the experience itself
and that was like an epiphany for me
maybe it was obvious to others but i
just never really thought about it from
the same
perspective that i was engaging in our
work at neuroscape which is
creating these experiences as medicine
and once i realized that i was like oh
this is it this is the area that i can
contribute to in a unique way because of
the work that i've done at neuroscape
and also i believe elevate this field
because it is the area
of psychedelic research and psychedelic
science that i think
is most efficient and missing in order
for it to
translate most effectively and so with
that i began a journey throughout
2019 and 20 to meet
the people that were shaping this field
to read the literature and really
understand that the potential here
so everyone from michael pollan himself
to robin carr at harris i went to
gave a talk at imperial college uh and
oxford
in in the uk uh rick doblin
you and i talked a lot and you made
other introductions and i
started expanding my mind about the
potential for psychedelic
compounds to lead to really
profound and transformative outcomes
through
experience that was the part that really
captured my imagination
and then i started really reading
robin's papers
carefully and he has a lot of them and
he is you know he's the most cited
researcher in the field and you know
he's a young guy and
i just really respected what i saw
from him as a scientist his own risk
taking and but his rigor
and the depth that he approaches a
problem the review articles he wrote
and then i started reading about his
articles on context
which is essentially what i've been
talking about how
the elements what in the field is known
as set and setting
how you enter into a treatment what is
your makeup already what are your
intentions
and what occurs during it what do you
hear are you listening to music
are are there other elements of safety
around you that take you
through that experience to a certain
outcome and he's written about this both
at their sort of review article level
where he's surveying the field
and then from work that he's done
himself with music during treatments
so i was inspired by his work but i also
realized that
what i was seeing was that everyone
in the field that i talked to whether
they were therapists or
shamans from south south america or
researchers at hopkins
everyone agrees that this element
of context that the experience itself
is critical for the outcome is
universally agreed upon i've never heard
really any deviation from that
but the ingredients that go into the
recipe of that experience that lead to
the most
favorable and enduring outcomes is
unknown
now there are definitely therapists that
have experimented for many years with
context and are experts in it but
if you're looking for prospectively
designed randomized trials that have
started
dissecting these elements and learning
who they work best
for and what conditions there's almost
nothing in the literature that shows
that
and so once i really realized that i
said this is an incredible opportunity
to make an impact in a field that
already has so much potential
and to really fill in that gap that i
saw and then it was meeting robin
finding each other sharing this passion
and realizing that we could do more
together and that neuroscape is a
perfect environment
in order to do this type of work because
of the effort we already had
in experiences medicine and as you said
it seems like
there is there's quite a bit of basic
science that's been done we have then
the clinical trials
so advanced clinical trials later stage
clinical trials but there is this
in a sense gap in the middle
and there are people who will have
context
that they decide or assume or perhaps on
some level even test to be effective
that they take through
trials but they're not doing and this is
going to be a maybe a
primitive way of looking at it the sort
of multivariate
testing because they don't they don't
have
the expertise of the equipment to do so
right they don't have the team to do so
but you have a multi-modal biosensing
capabilities multi-sensory integration
work
within neuroscape so i'd be curious to
hear you speak to what capabilities
you're looking forward to exploiting
in the exploration and testing of these
things
yeah let's dive into it i just i just
want to pause because we may
went over it a little fast of this sits
in the middle
between what and i didn't really clarify
that so
the reason i say it sits in the middle
is because on on the
let's say on the left side at the
beginning there's all the really great
basic science this is the work that's
done in a dish of like a
culture of neurons or in animal models
and understanding what these
compounds lsds you know the the elements
of sulci ben what what they what they're
doing
at the level of the cell are they
anti-inflammatory are they plasticity
inducing really just the basic you know
what receptors they bind to
an incredible amount of great work in
that domain and then on the other side
let's say the right there is all the
advanced
phase two now approaching phase three
clinical trials so these large
multi-site trials
with populations in need like
post-traumatic stress disorder and
depression
alcoholism end-of-life treatment
addiction amazing clinical work showing
benefit and so the middle is all of
the stuff that you need to go from the
basic science insights
into the clinical trials that is the
middle that we're talking about is
missing
how do you optimize the delivery how do
you make it
personalized to the individual how do
you make it precisely targeted
to those neural mechanisms that most
need to be
improved that's the error that's the
middle that i see
completely pretty much completely vacant
and that's the opportunity
that excites us at neuroscape that we
want to explore
so i think i define that that area that
opportunity a little better
let's let's dive into how do you do that
um this is a
another intersection that i find
fascinating and have for a long time is
the role of technology in neuroscience
and not just in the research but in its
translation
a perfect example is a video game as a
technology
that we have now used as a research tool
and now have
cleared as a therapeutic how can
technology play a role in understanding
the middle the role of sentence setting
in inducing a positive outcome
so there are really two ways that i'm
excited about
uh proceeding with that and our team at
neuroscape is already proficient in that
so
we're quite prepared for robin to land
and then you know sort of
hit the ground running hit the ground
running and we're we're writing grants
we're
we're buying equipment we're already
we're already running even though
he hasn't arrived here yet and so
let's think about it this way here you
are you can imagine yourself
going through a treatment like this at a
university and you're taking a compound
maybe you're familiar with it maybe
you're not
let's say psilocybin and it's a
reasonably high dose you're going to
have a
pretty strong experience and our goal is
that you end up on the other side of the
experience in
at least the same place hopefully a
better place
now right now if you were in a study
with that design at a university
anywhere in the world
you would likely be laying down with
therapists you would have already had
several sessions
so you would have been well prepped with
there would be that element of set
of going into this you would have been
screened for
conditions that might interact
unfavorably with this treatment
like schizophrenia and other conditions
that we that are avoided at least for
now
and you would then ingest this and have
usually a blindfold on an eye mask so
you
it was more internal you weren't seeing
things and you'd be listening to music
and that music would vary across sight
it may not even be music that you
actually like
but that is the design right now and
then after you would have the support
during the session and after the session
you would have several
other therapist-led meetings to help
process and integrate what you went
through and then follow up and that's
that's the basic design and it's a good
one and it's one that we've been really
using for decades even in the 60s
similar designs to this
and it's good methodology and it's
getting better and better
what i see missing there in
understanding the middle part
is the first thing is we don't really
know what's going on with a participant
during the treatment itself you sort of
a black box
now an extremely good therapist that has
done this for 40 years
is picking up subtle verbalizations or
body movements or changes in your facial
expression
and and they're able to protect you if
you need it
or help you know just sit with you as
you go through some challenges
and that's as good as it gets but that's
not really scalable at any level because
you can't have
as many experts as there are people in
need of a treatment like this so
that's the first opportunity and i'm
going to talk about that
in a moment and the other opportunity is
a blindfold
and a mask the best option is music
really ideal and what type of music and
what about all the other senses that we
have how we smell and feel
and other aspects of hearing that that
are not being
used during these treatments unknown so
used
in the real world of therapy but not
really studied we don't know who they're
best in
so that's the the second domain so let's
split those off so the first domain is
recording so we have a system at ucsf we
call multimodal biosensing
and my hypothesis is that with enough
sensor technologies not just looking at
brain activity but looking across the
whole spectrum
of physiology and behavior so high
density eeg
facial expression electrodermal activity
heart rate and its variability looking
at facial expressions
body movements doing experience sampling
either through vocalizations or using
joysticks so that there is some degree
of communication
my hypothesis is that not one single of
those
signals are going to tell us about the
state of that individual during a
treatment
but if we can collect them rapidly
in real time and integrate them use
machine learning approaches so that we
can
look for the patterns of what's the most
meaningful data we will be able to plot
the experience landscape of an
individual
traveling through a treatment like this
we won't know the content we won't
necessarily know that they're
picturing uh the details of a traumatic
event in their
lives but we i believe
that we will be able to tell their level
of arousal
the valence of it is it positive or
negative so
putting that together their stress the
state of stress
their attention whether their attention
is internally directed or externally
directed
as well as hopefully even a sense of
their awareness of what's going on
so real-time state recording as
implemented through multimodal
biosensing that's a
very high tech endeavor but it is
possible
right now it takes an like a real
multidisciplinary team so you're talking
neuroscientists
as well as people on the clinical side
biosensor technology experts
signal processing machine learning it is
a real
challenge and it has not been
accomplished yet anywhere in the world
at any level
that allows us to really track state so
that's the first
challenge that we want to really tackle
is
using technology to understand the state
of the person
while they go through a treatment the
other side of it
is starting to manipulate all of these
levers of context
of the setting and the set so how do we
position them through different
information that presented different
environments before the treatment
and then during the treatment not just
think about
music with eyes closed sure we will do
that that is the standard approach right
now
but what is it like to look around you
to see either light or abstract views or
views of nature
to smell a forest when you see it and
when you hear it what we call
multi-sensory integration
to feel low frequency vibrations through
your bodies as you enter into these
different environments
all of that is unexplored and so by
putting these things
together we start understanding
the journey the journey within the
treatment itself
how these little you know not little to
the individual but these
discrete moments in time these
micro experiences along the way how
they're
influenced by the context of the
environment that we're able to control
around the participant and then how all
of these elements
add up to an outcome to a sense of
well-being
or joy or mystical perspective that
occurs
after so how do we connect the events
that occur during the treatment
with the outcomes all of that is
unexplored and that's basically what
we're going to be focusing on
there is so much room for
experimentation so many variables
there's a lifetime there i i always say
to rob and i was like we will die
before all that that you just heard is
figured out
so much it's incredibly exciting to me
for many reasons and just to give a
snapshot of personal experience here
that raises questions i think related to
those that you'll be exploring in a very
methodical tech enabled way
so that you can actually measure capture
and quantify these discrete
events discrete changes i recall
the first time i did a
five-session series of infusions
this is intravenous infusions of
ketamine
and in this case i wasn't using it
because suffering from acute depression
nor
chronic pain those are two indications
but i wanted to be able to speak
to the effects and possible side effects
after effects
of ketamine treatment if i were asked
which i knew i would be asked
and what really
stuck out to me among other things in
this ketamine treatment that it was the
first time i had been seated in a chair
and that video had been put on for me
and i was asked to select
a dvd
it was very retro in that sense
but and i was able to choose a dvd that
i then used
as a constant throughout my
sessions i didn't change the video
because i i didn't want
that to be a sort of an uncontrolled
variable
and these these aren't i'm not
pretending that these are these are
really tightly
controlled but i was trying to minimize
the number of variables
so i kept this constant as this video
and i'd never in a deep psychedelic
experience which you can
certainly have with ketamine at
sufficient enough doses
even though it is a bit bizarre as a
dissociative anesthetic
i never had the experience of attempting
even attempting to watch video
in these states so to observe how the
imagery
and this isn't i suppose on some level
surprising because
internally generated imagery can
certainly have a tremendous effect but
to observe how the imagery affected the
experience how the music on the video
affected the experience
how closing my eyes were opening my eyes
while
being exposed to this external stimulus
affected my experience
was very new it was very novel to me
that's not what usually happens if you
are
in a supervised setting certainly within
a university context right
it's more or less what you described
it's like okay i hold on lay down
we have pretty good evidence to suggest
that this at least doesn't interfere
with reasonably good outcomes but
there's so much fine
tuning and assumption testing
that can be done and then you will be
doing it's it's incredibly exciting to
me
that's great to hear yeah when i first
started
putting the meat on the bones and saying
okay this is this is something exciting
robin's interested i have my leadership
at ucsf
is behind me you know creating this i
felt
nervous because this is a new field to
me
and it has a lot of history right
there's a lot of therapists that have
been doing this for decades and
obviously the indigenous cultures around
the world have used these as
as not just mental health tools but as
religious and spiritual and
i wanted to dive into that part and
determine if anything that
i have just said to you is offensive to
them
you know i just was was curious
how it would be received because it is
very very different than
how these experiences are often
delivered
throughout history and i was really
surprised to find
that especially on the multi-sensory
stimulation side
therapists that i talked with were
really
receptive to it that they thought that
this is actually what they mean when
they say shamanism it is
this act of environment
tuning and creating to help guide that
journey and
they feel that they're maybe pretty good
at it because they've been doing it for
a long time but they were certainly open
to
having data that they could reach for
that would give them more fine-tuning
and also recognizing how hard it is to
train people that are new to this
and that if there was a library of
stimuli and and evidence of who it works
and how it works and
also their ability to know what's really
happening
inside an individual's mind they were
very
very uh activated by that now i'm sure
that won't be
true for everyone but that was really
reassuring and and the last part i want
to make on this was
my my big goal here is not to say
we don't need therapists anymore we
don't need humans in the loop we have
enough
technological advancements in terms of
sensor technology and machine learning
and artificial intelligence that we're
good
we we just need you to take this step
into
the box and come out fixed and i really
actually do not believe that that
is the future we will or should have
i think that what we're doing here is
building a set of
tools really sophisticated informed
data-driven tools that will allow a
therapist
or you know any practitioner in the
space to be more effective
at helping their patient that is what i
hope and believe will come from
this long journey and that technology
will be what it always
should be is it just another human tool
so that's where i hope and do believe
that we will end
when we go through this research
approach looking at
achilles and endeavor rx for a moment
because i i'm tying these things
together in my own mind i'd love for you
to stress test
what i'm about to say in treating not
just children with adhd but
patient populations or populations with
autism with depression
these different conditions and talking
about
how it is possible that a single
intervention
can be efficacious across multiple
conditions this
conversation or related questions
translates quite well
to the study of psychedelics and
certainly robin carhart harris talks a
lot about the
default mode network and how and why
it appears that some of these compounds
are therapeutically effective or at
least
appear to be the data suggest that they
are
effective across a pretty wide range of
conditions that most
or many people would assume are not
related at face value
right so you have different types of
addiction including
alcohol use disorder opiate use disorder
that's open use disorder forthcoming at
hopkins
and then you have ptsd you have
treatment resistant depression as well
as major depressive disorder
there are people looking at ocd
and the assumptions of which
or the one of the assumptions underlying
the the cross
efficacy is that perhaps there's this
commonality
this common kind of neurological
correlate with the default mode network
that there's a sort of a rigidity
associated with these various behaviors
that is attenuated with psychedelics
so i'm just in my own mind observing
sort of a similarity
between the software development and
then the
testing within psychedelics will be
doing the question that i have
is do you envision
looking at how much like
is automatically achieved with software
there's an adaptive component where you
are able to determine
over time for a single subject a
sequence of experiences that is
adaptive in some way mm-hmm does that
make sense
you mentioned this earlier and just in
case some listeners didn't catch it
endeavor rx adapts to the user right
it's kind of like a personal trainer who
increases the weights in certain
movements over time so you have
progressive resistance
and therefore greater adaptation
do you think that that is an area you'll
be exploring or that you would like to
explore how
you can adapt a series of psychedelic
experiences for an individual
to be customized undoubtedly it was
really
really a great statement and question
that i want to just take a moment and
unpack from my perspective because
i think you know as we as we've had this
conversation
people could be lost of weight are you
building video games you're working on
psychedelics like where where are the
threads here
it is the same thing that we're talking
about all along
this is the power of experience
to change the brain what a neuroscience
would be known as
experience dependent plasticity whether
that experience
occurs with or without a molecule
it has the power to transform you
in an incredibly profound way and it
could be positive or it could be
negative
that is what ptsd is right you could
just witness something
so horrendous that your brain
functions differently from there on out
right that is
the negative side of this story that is
what i've been working on how to build
experiences we do a lot of work with
virtual reality now multi-sensory
experiences
i believe will have even more profound
outcomes and
more transformative effects and we don't
put any compounds on board right that's
that's what neuroscape basically does
now now
expand the conversation and we're
talking about these
psychedelic compounds and there's a
broad array of them so we
won't break them all down and they're
all different in some way in the effects
they have
but they really have these two features
that are most
fascinating to me one is that they they
shuffle the deck right in many ways they
they break down
they break down the the rigid sort of
frameworks that you go into the
experience with
and that is a combination of changes in
default network and also many there are
many networks in the brain big
big large scale networks and their
interaction leads to you
and leads to your consciousness and so
those are shifted
leading to the opportunity to reform
them adam let me just pause here for a
second when you say they lead to you
that means your conception of self like
when i say i am
tim that is what you mean from every
level
your your ego your your reflection about
your identity
but also your position in space
and in time and your relation to
other elements of the universe and the
world around you
all of that is fluid more fluid
right and that is because these networks
that may
dictate your own reflection of who you
are or how time is passing or how you
perceive
light or sound or touch are
distorted from the norm thus allowing a
complete
re-discovery of of you and
the world around you that's one very
profound piece of it
and the other is that they induce
neuroplasticity and robin talks about
this all the time when he presents his
work and that is also
incredibly fascinating because it's not
just
that these compounds enrich
or change an experience which they
clearly do
they also are plasticity inducing
meaning that the
changes that occur have a greater
potential to endure
now this would be really a bad thing if
you have a negative experience which is
i think part of what has occurred over
the last
half century is realizing that in an
uncontrolled environment that you may be
threatened
while on a compound like these the
effects can be
way worse than if you were not on them
so this is the
you know the yin and yang the plus and
minus that everything has
is that we now realize that the
experience
since that is what evokes the outcome
needs to be positive
or at least not that suffering can occur
but at least needs to be nurturing in a
way that leads to a positive outcome
so i just wanted to make that connection
is that it's really about
experience and large-scale neural
networks that cross multiple domains
and plasticity and that is the common
feature that unites
all the work that we do at neuroscape
whether it's non-invasive brain
stimulation
new approaches to neurofeedback video
closely with video game technology or
now psychedelics
so just to put that together because you
you made the leap between endeavor rx
and this work
and now to just answer your question
more specifically
about closed loop systems so let's just
pause and just
make sure that everyone's on the same
page with that so
probably what makes endeavor rx so
unique as well as the dozen other
video game technologies that we have at
neuroscape from mediterranean to engage
labyrinth we just had a paper on body
brain trainer they're all closed loop
and what that means is that real time
data about your state and it may be very
simple data like your performance data
how fast or accurate you are
feeds into a processor a computer
that records that data makes a decision
about it and then updates your
environment
the challenges that you're experiencing
the stimuli
the rewards that you're being exposed to
and it goes on and on
constantly adapting that's why i made
the analogy to a personal trainer
imagine going to a gym and having a
trainer that has access to
every aspect about you in the moment and
also this ability to change things so
subtly to just push you to the next
level that is
what this closed-loop system does now
we've been doing that for a decade with
all sorts of
experiences delivered in virtual reality
and on tablets and you know some of them
are
eyes closed meditative experiences
others are rapid
fast-paced action experiences but that's
what we do
now let's talk about psychedelics so i
described to you a system
where technology enables multimodal
biosensing
so we can understand your state in real
time
and i described us having the ability
to change what you see hear smell
and feel and so we have the two sides we
have the ability to know what's going on
with you and we have the ability
to shape your environment what we didn't
talk about is what you just said
creating a closed-loop psychedelic
experience that is the goal here
that we can have let's say a therapist
sitting in front of a patient or a
participant in a research study
having access to this data maybe they
have to you know if you want to be
science fiction here picture them in
virtual reality watching
a four-dimensional representation of
your experience of their patients
experience
unfold to see are they in high stress
are they
are they suffering now okay it's okay
for them to suffer but only for 15
minutes because
our data shows that after that then it
starts becoming more likely to cause
harm than to help
and so they're watching this unfold and
then they have these tools right
they can say oh this is the time where
it's worth
to move out of this high stress
deep internal attention high arousal
high awareness moment and bring it out
and in order to do that what i'm going
to do
is move them into a forest where they
could smell
pine and hear a waterfall and feel low
you know frequency vibration across
their body and that will
ease them out and then we'll have
another day where we can go deep again
this is the closed loop we're using
real-time data and it can be done
just with machine learning itself and a
processor or a human on board like i
just described
that's how we could create personalized
experiences that are targeting
those aspects of their brain function
that need to be improved whether they're
suffering and they have a pathology or
they're just trying to enhance and
elevate their minds
just imagining an electro facilitator
with a within some type of minority
report
like virtual reality grabbing stimuli
adding them or subtracting them
combining them
like the swedish chef adding ingredients
it's quite a picture it's quite a
picture and it's
i mean you see and you say science
fiction but
i i think these things are may end up
being closer than people
anticipate and furthermore
i just want to say that the research
you'll be doing the experimentation
brings up i find this tremendously
exciting so many
challenging questions i'm not going to
say problems but so many challenging
questions
for instance you just alluded to this
but when does it make
sense to increase
or expose someone to increase stress
speaking just end of one actually it's
more than end of one because i have
friends who would who would share this
opinion that
many of all to speak for myself many of
my most
impactful experiences with psychedelics
that had
positive durable effects
were very challenging experiences
in safe environments and so determining
like what the dose
what the appropriate dose of distress is
if there is one is such
a fascinating question right because
there there
is a point where the dose makes the
poison and all of a sudden someone comes
out and they're destabilized for two
weeks
potentially longer right so where how do
you thread that needle it's
very hard to even if it's sorry to
run but but even if an experienced
say indigenous healer could
intuit that and do it effectively
while that is incredibly impressive it
does
not increase the
availability of psychedelics as a
therapeutic tool because
that is a spider sense or some innate or
trained ability that takes a very long
time to develop
so you can't just copy and paste it but
if all of a sudden like you said you
have this
library of data you have
evidence to suggest where the tipping
point is
and when you should introduce that
forest
i mean the the implications are really
staggering
yeah i won't even repeat it you said it
perfectly
it would be silly i mean that is exactly
what what has excited me here
and and then when i found out that those
therapists and
indigenous shaman they were like yeah we
would like to know
that data too you know like even the
experts but the ability
now what i'm really lit up by is talking
to those individuals allying with them
and saying
what and i've done this several times
now and it's so much fun to say
okay you've been doing this for 40 years
when you're sitting in front in front of
someone
how do you know if they're suffering and
when do you decide to help them out to
like
lay hands on them or to introduce some
sense which is what they do
and you know they'll talk about and i'm
taking notes they'll be like well
i could see their face change i'm like
perfect i could record facial
expressions pretty easily with either
camera or an electrode
they'll be like well sometimes they
vocalize also very very accessible to to
us right now
and so that's what's really fun about
designing these research studies is not
doing it
from some academic halls and some and
even resting on the scientific
literature itself because a lot of this
is not recorded
in papers but it's out there in the
world in
true life wisdom and expertise that's
been accumulated over
you know sometimes centuries but finding
those
nuggets and then using the tools that i
described and doing
very carefully controlled research
studies that would be
accepted by even the most conservative
of regulatory agencies or professionals
out there
to move this forward and as you said to
make it
accessible there is not nearly enough
experts in the world for all the people
in need
i mean not even by an order of magnitude
so we have to figure this out or this is
just going to be
you know a tool for the elite right and
just won't have the access that we need
it to
one thing i really appreciate about you
is and with respect to this area
i wouldn't say in particular but it's a
good example you have spent
an incredible amount of time and i know
this because we've had so many
conversations over the last few years
with
practitioners who operate with different
compounds
in many different environments with
different populations
in different geographies who have
stylistically different approaches
and you have as you mentioned not
sequestered yourself in this ivory tower
of
literature as your sole source of input
and
one challenge within the psychedel
community is that there's no such
thing as a psychedelic community there
are in fact what i would consider
factions in a sense i mean you have kind
of the the scientific group
you have now by scientific let me
qualify
you have scientists people are actually
doing the work
you have uh well-educated
folks who are secular who succumb to a
certain degree of sciencism
scientism i'm not sure what you would
call it but those who aren't really
scientifically
literate but view it dogmatically almost
like a religion
then you go all the way to the other
side you have people who might
embrace indigenous traditions or some
hybrid say neoshamanic approach along
the lines of
or western psychotherapeutic approach
along the lines of say
leo for a stand graph and there's a lot
of friction
amongst these groups i'm not surprised
on one level because humans are humans
and there's a lot of kind of tribal
impulse readily available at any moment
but
to what would you attribute people thus
far in your experience
from these many different worlds and
there's a whole spectrum
being open and interested in the work
that you're doing because
my experience has been that very often
the scientists
don't really want to embrace
indigenous or facilitator wisdom and
view it as hocus pocus hand wavy woo-woo
superstition and then on the flip side
you have the people
who are on the not necessarily
indigenous side i actually find a lot of
the indigenous very people who have a
lineage
of this quite open-minded but sort of in
the neo-shamanic space are very
dismissive of scientists and view it as
overly reductionist
and missing the point on some level long
question but
why do you think people have responded
so positively to you
i think because at the fundamental level
everyone recognizes that this is
experiential medicine
and that is how i i start the
conversation i don't know the best
experience to
to lead to the best outcome and i'm not
approaching this
in a very rigid way of this is the
approach
that i think is going to lead to the
best outcomes i'm just suggesting that
thinking about this is a drug
from the point of view of molecule leads
to effect
you take this antibiotic
the biot is killed you're better that's
not what we're talking about here
we're talking about the creation of an
experience
that is undoubtedly induced
or accelerated or enhanced by these
compounds
but the nature of the experience
leading to outcomes i think everyone
agrees upon that basic framework
so if you enter the conversation with
that as
the ground truth i think that there is
a lot more likelihood of reaching at
least you know a common
a commonality of view that don't we want
to understand the experience more
don't we want to be able to guide some
of it's just
language the word control which we use
in science all the time is not
a particularly warm word
when it comes to you know to to a
person's life who's suffering so
yes okay but the word guide is a lot
more favorable now
we're sort of many times not all times
talking about similar things there
we're not talking about pushing you into
this place
we're talking about presenting you with
options to enter this place and
you know so some of it is just being
really
very careful about language
understanding the person's perspective
that you're talking to being
respectful of the amount of time and
expertise
they have and then just returning to the
ground truth that this is an
experiential medicine and there's so
much more we could learn
in order to help more people and that is
where i
find that there's a great commonality
well adam i couldn't be more excited i'm
going to ask you in a minute
you know what the future looks like
and how people can help certainly and
where they can
find you and i have those notes in front
of me so
not that you would need me to remind you
of your own urls
but before we sort of wind
to a close for this conversation
is there anything else that you would
like to
say to my audience
to request of listeners question you
would like to post anything at all that
you would like to say before we
get to the question of next steps and
how people
can help if they would like to help yeah
i mean just at a high level
i would just like to remind everyone
that
to keep an open mind uh you might have
heard things that
we've talked about that are completely
in your
your wheelhouse that you're just like so
fired up like that's exactly what i love
and
others that might feel threatened by it
or that it's
distorting the real value
of these medicines but i just encourage
you to keep an open mind and realize
that the underlying goal here
is that there is so much suffering
in the world and we have done such an
atrocious job of addressing that
if you look across the fields of cardiac
health
and infectious disease despite the fact
that we're in a pandemic now
we've done so much better than we have
in terms of mental suffering
and the idea that there's a magic brain
pill out there that's going to fix it is
just not going to happen it's not true
of these compounds either
we have to be really creative in how we
think about
treatments and how we use science and
technology to get there
so i just encourage people to keep an
open mind you don't have to agree with
everything you've heard
but the need is great and the
opportunity
is here now so i thank you for for your
patience
in in in listening and going on this
journey with tim and i
neuroescape.ucsf.edu
just to reiterate i'm so optimistic
about
this new chapter within your escape and
for you also
this is a big commitment for you for a
multitude of reasons and
i think a lot of people will be
similarly excited
and galvanized by this because you have
ucsf
which is from a science medicine
research perspective as blue chip as it
comes
it is not a an institution that has been
heavily associated with psychedelics in
any way previously
your lab has also not been associated
with psychedelics
previously and i think
that it will hopefully inspire many
people to take a close look
at these tools these medicines and
and research associated with it i think
it's going to be incredibly validating
for the space and for that i'm
incredibly grateful how can people help
what are some of the next steps are you
looking for
financial support what are you looking
to do and what do you need to do it
yeah you know we we need we need a lot
of help right
it takes a village and we have great
people on board already
jenny mitchells is leading a site for
the maps trial at neuroscape in this in
our division right now so we
we already have some early momentum
robin of course is coming on board and
couldn't be more excited by what he's
going to add to this
so we have a great team and we have ucsf
support
but we need a little bit more of
everything so
there may be listeners that have
experience
with the perspective that i just shared
in terms of the experiential the set and
setting
they might have it from personal
experience they might have it as a
practitioner
or as a scientist from any viewpoint i
want to hear about it
we want to be informed and as we talked
about him not just based upon a
literature but based upon
all of this real world data that has
accumulated over time
and so that that is one need right there
just educate us
how would you like to hear about it is
uh hitting you on twitter
is there an email that is not going to
bury you
yeah forever yeah well
on gazali.com there's a contact site and
that would be
a great way and i'll share with my team
and so yeah so
you know we want to be educated and one
of my sort of
tenants is not to just think that we
know everything and in this case none of
us do no one and so
the contact information on there and the
way to offer that
perspective to us is open we probably
won't be able to reply to everyone but
you will be heard
and and that information will be shared
and and it could it could help
inspire research and and our own
perspectives
so website gazali
g-a-z-z-a-l-e-y-dot-com
the next is is financial support we have
done well
we have over six million dollars in
funding which is enough to get
robin here and supported and to build
out our first set of studies and to hire
some great postdocs and bring on some
junior faculty
but it doesn't go that far when you're
talking about the type of
division that i just described to you
and and the research objectives we have
so there's lots of opportunity we want
to build a new cutting edge facility
at neuroscape with multiple laboratories
so that we can do more
research more rapidly and so
philanthropic support is
always welcome at any level and again
you could contact me through there
there's also contact on their escape
site if
if that's more palatable to you whatever
whatever way you want to reach out
and let us know if you would like to be
part of the funding
of this endeavor would be incredibly
appreciated
do you have a target raise amount
that you're able to disclose or would
you prefer not to have any
specific number as a target when i first
formulated this and then put the team
together and we we brainstormed about
what we wanted to accomplish over the
next five years
in terms of building the team
in terms of having the research tools
that we need
in terms of building the facilities
because we have space to actually create
some new
labs very cutting edge labs that
bring this type of technology but not in
an intrusive way to maintain
the natural feel and the warmth that's
tricky so
this design challenges in order to
accomplish that
our goal was 20 million dollars so we we
have a ways to go
now adding 10 million dollars right now
would allow us to actually build the
facility
that will unlock a massive amount so
that's sort of what
i've been keeping in my my mind when i
look towards what i hope
that will accomplish over the course of
this year wonderful
and not to act as the pro bono
development officer here you have
capable folks at ucsf for that but i
will just say for folks who
who may be wondering i have some skin in
the game here i'm a big believer huge
believer
in you adam and neuroscape and have been
for a very long time so
i i am also through my foundation
contributing
some capital and i would imagine
that people can donate appreciated
securities
i.e stocks and possibly other things do
you know if
ucsf is able to receive
cryptocurrencies of any type it's a
great question
a good time to investigate that yeah
that is a great
great question and i will find out later
today
wonderful and i know that you and i have
the mutual acquaintance of rick doblin
maps
has in the past figured out ways to
accept
cryptocurrency and in fact some of their
largest donations have come
from mr apple maybe mr pineapple
as as he is known through i believe is
bitcoin but through cryptocurrency so
just uh be good to investigate
and if you are able to do that or if
there's an approach to that we can put
it in the show notes at tim not blog
podcast for people who may be interested
this just in breaking news yes ucsf can
now
accept cryptocurrencies for neuroscape
and the work that adam will be doing
i believe this could be a first for a
major university it's a very big deal
and i'm supporting his work if you would
like to support his work
through cryptocurrency you can do that
and all you need to do is email
neuroescape
ucsf.edu that's n-e-u-r-o-s-c-a-p-e
at ucsf.edu and they
can provide you with instructions for
how to do this
and now back to our conversation adam
i'm excited for you
i'm excited for the the future of this
field i'm excited for your team i'm
excited for
robin and the people
not yet determined who may contribute or
join the team in some fashion
and i really appreciate you taking the
time to hop on the phone
especially looking like old man time you
have
you have a big beard right now which
suits you i like it i like it and
and for those who are wondering about
the visual he so adam has been i don't
know how long you've been the silver fox
i mean you have
you have since pretty much since college
i mean you look kind of like i mean not
exactly but like storm from the x-men
you have perfectly white hair luscious
locks of white hair and now you you have
full head coverage with this incredible
beard
and it's it's a great look i like it
thanks tim tim i just want to say before
we jump off thank you so much
for your inspiration and and now you're
supporting this your support over the
years
um not just financially but in every way
you've been
you've been a great friend and and a
great colleague to have on this journey
and it's just i'm buzzing right now at
how
how much fun i had just going down
memory lane and then looking to the
future
so just i know your your listeners
already appreciate what you bring
and you know i have my own perspective
as being a long time friend and
i just want to thank you for always
giving
all of my ideas an outlet and and your
attention
and then helping to share it with your
listeners so thank you so much
oh thanks adam i love you and your
family very
much i can't wait to give you a proper
hug in meat space this virtual [ __ ] is
for the birds i'm yes
we'll we'll get there eventually and uh
hopefully
hopefully in a few months in fact and
i can't wait until we can actually break
bread and have a drink
together so thank you thanks again for
taking the time and to everybody
listening
this is exciting stuff check adam out
gazali.com as mentioned g-a-z-z-a-l-e-y
dot com
neuroscape which honestly even if you
have zero interest in psychedelics just
for the other work that they've done
neuroscape.ucsf
is well worth checking out it is a
glimpse of the future
as far as i'm concerned you can find
them on twitter at adamgaz
gaz which is also the handle on
instagram
and facebook we will have show notes for
everything
including hopefully an update on whether
or not
neuroscape and adam can accept
cryptocurrencies because
adam makes and his team make
incredibly capital efficient use of
funds
they are like a lean fast growing
well executed startup that is part of
the reason i've been
so enthusiastically supportive and i
encourage people to take a look
so i've links to everything yet tim dot
blog
forward slash podcast and thanks for
tuning in hey guys this is tim again
just a few more things before you take
off
number one this is five bullet friday
do you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every friday
that provides a little morsel of fun
before the weekend and five bullet
friday is a very short email
where i share the coolest things i've
found or that i've been pondering over
the week
that could include favorite new albums
that i've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that i've somehow dug up in
the
the world of the esoteric as i do it
could include
favorite articles that i've read and
that i've shared with
my close friends for instance and it's
very short it's just a little
tiny bite of goodness before you head
off for the weekend so if you want to
receive
that check it out just go to four
hourworkweek.com that's
4hourworkweek.com all spelled out and
just drop in
your email and you will get the very
next one and if you sign up
i hope you enjoy it this episode is
brought to you by
all form if you've been listening to
this podcast for a while you've probably
heard me talk about helix
sleep and their mattresses which i've
been using since 2017. i have two of
them
upstairs from where i'm sitting at this
moment and now helix has gone beyond the
bedroom and started making
sofas they just launched a new company
called all form a-l-l-f-o-r-m and
they're making premium
customizable sofas and chairs shipped
right to your door at a fraction of the
cost
of traditional stores so i'm sitting in
my living room right now and it's
entirely all form furniture i've got two
chairs i've got an ottoman and i have an
l sectional
couch and i'll come back to that you can
pick your fabric
they're all spill stained and scratch
resistant the soap color
the color of the legs the surface size
the shape to make sure it's perfect for
you and your home
also all form arrives in just three to
seven days and you can assemble it all
yourself in a few minutes no tools
needed i was quite astonished by how
modular
and easy these things fit together kind
of like lego pieces they've got arm
chairs
love seats all the way up to an eight
seat sectional so there's something for
everyone
you can also start small and kind of
build on top of it if you want to get a
smaller couch and then build
out on it which is actually in a way
what i did because i can turn
my l-sectional couch into a normal
straight couch and then with a separate
ottoman
in a matter of about 60 seconds it's
pretty rad so
i mentioned i have all these different
things in this room i use the natural
leg finish which is their lightest color
and i dig it i mean i've been using
these things hours and hours and hours
every single day so i am using
what i am sharing with you guys and if
getting a sofa without trying it in
store sounds risky you don't need to
worry all form sofas are delivered
directly to your home with fast free
shipping
and you get 100 days to decide if you
want to keep it that's more than three
months and if you don't love it they'll
pick it up for free and give you a full
refund
your sofa frame also has a forever
warranty that's literally
forever so check it out take a look
they've got all sorts of cool stuff
to choose from i was skeptical and it
actually worked it worked
much better than i could have imagined
and i'm very very happy so
to find your perfect sofa check out
allform.com
tim that's a-l-l-f-o-r-m.com
tim all form is offering 20 off all
orders to you my dear listeners at
allform.com
tim make sure to use the code tim at
checkout
that's allforum.com tim and use code tim
at checkout this episode is brought to
you by
expressvpn what is vpn
virtual private network it's an app that
you run on your computer or your mobile
device it secures your internet
connection
hides your public ip address and lets
you bypass regional restrictions on
content and i actually asked my
followers on twitter
1.5 or 1.6 million of you for
vpn recommendations your favorites many
wrote back that expressvpn
was their favorite including a number of
people who've been on this podcast
so i gave it a shot and it is
ridiculously
fast to the extent that i thought i
didn't have it on
to give you an idea expressvpn is
consistently rated the fastest vpn
service on the market
it's incredibly easy to use and it's one
two three just download the app tap one
button and you're connected to a secure
vpn server so expressvpn what are we
talking about here
sourcevpn is great for when you need to
get work done while you're on some
sketchy wi-fi network for instance and
i've had
a number of hacker friends of mine
showing how easy it is to snoop on
public wi-fi
just by downloading simple apps you do
not need a computer science background
to do that which scares the hell out of
me
so if you don't want to be a victim of
that you can use
expressvpn expressvpn is useful not only
for entrepreneurs
and remote workers and travelers like
yours truly
but really for anyone who wants
protection from being snooped on or
having their personal data
stolen so i use it constantly when i'm
in airports coffee shops and so on
any public wi-fi really you just use the
internet like you normally would
but with expressvpn encrypting all of
your network traffic to safeguard your
data
let's check it out visit my special link
at expressvpn.com
tim and you'll get an extra three months
of expressvpn protection for free
that's expressvpn.com tim to claim your
special deal
visit expressvpn.com time